[Musique]
halloween on est en direct on est bien
regardez il ya des retours un bon
watching et me regarde comme ils
déboulent en quoi donc j'ai des couilles
en or fois au joker et aux bébés on est
là pour s'amuser et emploie 3 4 en
diablesse ça très bien toi pourquoi
beetlejuice toi t'es quoi toi en zombies
alétois partie sia et toi ça m'en fous
ouais laxman et toi t'en quoi toi jack
sparrow franchement et vous auriez pu
vous déguiser quand même pas très bien
je trouve que c'est léger et vous vous
attends quoi bon dracula comme chaque
année sur dracula à tous les dirigeants
du monde tf1 nous priver d'un dinar
franchement c'est pas mal hein si vous
m'écoutez pas joséphine ange gardien
audois
je pars de l'idée bonjour
m
tg oui le mec qui me disait nabarro je
mettais une carte n'a pas attaqué à
sept-îles ici et venaient boire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle
il m'a serré la main ce qu'on m'a dit
j'ai pas les mains sales c'est ça depuis
tout à l'heure je vous les mettez à les
y oblige ça vous va très bien et la
jambe apparente est magnifique
franchement c'est très beau merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'en vois qui embrasse tout le monde
jennifer puisqu'on parle de slimane et
il a tenu à faire une surprise puisque
et non
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
niggli
tu faisais
on sait tous plantés c'est
quand même fort de se relever
[Musique]
c'est dans la ville
ça
ces kits je suis enfant bonjour merci on
aura dépolitisé encore parler moi vous
n'avez tout ça et on l'appelle chose on
se retrouve dans un oeuf pour les
enfants
[Applaudissements]
il est 18h15 est en direct comme tous
les soirs je suis très content de
retrouver pour touche pas à mon alors
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
valérie benaïm vous êtes ans qui vous
débutez beauté dit la vérité toute la
vérité
vous êtes fan de moi j'aimerais ça me
fait extrêmement plaisir mais même si tu
es merci mais non merci chérie tu es
très belle comme ça je ressemble à
quelqu'un qui est très beau cfoot
atteint ça c'est vrai oui si
[Rires]